la pop heart niveau taille et corpulent
c'est exactement pareil cas nous
venaient et pas mal de te laisser madame
emma béroud et oui c'est nous
[Musique]
alors question gay dernier excusez moi
c'est vous la sage femme
enfin le sage femme enfin on dit un sage
femme d'ailleurs d'ailleurs est alors
celle de caution carte de mutuelle
rectificatif de deux mois nous c'est
juste là c'est l'internet
vous vous sentez prêt pour l'arrivée de
l'enfant
le but est vraiment fin prêt paris
voudrait avoir une place en maternité
il faudra juste
une signature est une copie du cnap
évidemment du coût du certificat
national d'aptitude de la parentalité
le clap quoi elle m'appelle 10 c'est
quoi exactement vous faites l'essai un
examen obligatoire
vous pensez bien qu'on va pas vous
laisser avoir un enfant sans s'assurer
qu'ils aient les compétences pour
l'éduquer alors va falloir le passer en
express
cette situation met elle en danger la
vie de l'enfant et pensa oui répondent
les non répondeurs dû aller pour sauver
la pratique des femmes ouais ouais ouais
trop tard il faut changer ma couche si
changer pour que moi parce que charge
mentale
je crois que je dois pas perdre encore
[Musique]
tous raccordés me lacoste à mon sens
c'est peu
je préfère pêcher
c'est bon vous avez votre club 47 %
d'erreurs de monsieur norme ce avec les
faux culs les robots qui font pas
d'erreurs la perfection c'est terrible
ça inhibe l'enfant avec vous et moi n'y
a pas de risque par contre pour vous
c'est mort testez du merde
[Musique]